empezó la semana y en méxico la cifra de
muertos por coronavirus superó los 150
mil fallecimientos este país ha luchado
por contener la pandemia y es el cuarto
en el mundo con el número más alto de
muertos después de eeuu india y brasil-
de cada 100 personas que en su momento
se confirman se clasifican como casos de
kobe lamentablemente seis pierden la
vida consecuencias de las complicaciones
que también todos conocemos
esta enfermedad produce las autoridades
sanitarias de cuba reportaron un pico en
los casos nuevos de kobe 19 el gobierno
ordenó cerrar escuelas y canceló eventos
deportivos y culturales para ayudar a
reducir el número de infecciones con los
colombianos lamentaron la muerte del
ministro de defensa carlos holmes
trujillo quien fue víctima de una
neumonía viral relacionada con el cob y
19 el virus ha infectado hasta ahora más
de 2 millones de personas en este país y
más de 52 mil han muerto en venezuela la
comunidad científica es escéptica la
nueva medicina que el presidente nicolás
maduro promocionó en primera instancia
como la cura contra el coronavirus
solo para decir después que es un
tratamiento complementario pero ross a
las 40.000 muertes por el virus el
presidente francisco sagasti anunció que
el proceso de vacunación comenzará en
febrero con la llegada de un primer lote
de dosis habrá 40 en en lima y en otras
10 regiones del país desde el 31 de
enero hasta el 14 de febrero y se
mantendrá la restricción para los vuelos
internacionales procedentes de europa
una medida que incluye también a brasil
se limitan todas las actividades que
impliquen desplazamientos fuera de la
casa con excepción de tiendas de
abastecimiento de productos básicos con
un aforo del 40% los restaurants o pérez
harán sólo en modalidad de libre y se
autorizarán salidas peatonales una vez
al día por una hora
queda suspendido el transporte terrestre
y aéreo interprovincial y los
presidentes de chile y argentina- se
reunieron en santiago donde firmaron
varios acuerdos entre ellos uno para
luchar contra la pandemia ambos
mandatarios pidieron estrechar las
relaciones entre los países
latinoamericanos para enfrentar mejor la
crisis sanitaria y económica